what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty big news on the fantastic four if
you have been following the news about
the fantastic four project coming to the
mcu hopefully within a couple of years
you know that marvel studios recently
lost its director for the fantastic four
film john watts john watts of course
directed the spider-man homecoming
trilogy in which at the end we got
spider-man no way home one of the
greatest superhero movies of all time
however a lot came with directing
spider-man no way home and john watts
said that he just kind of wanted to take
a break from directing superhero films
however it was just announced that he
will be directing the skeleton crew
which is coming from star wars so he's
not taking too much of a break but they
are two very different franchises but
now the hunt for a new director is on
and we have a little bit of an update
about that today plus if we are getting
the fantastic four of course everybody
wants to know who the villain could be
now kang the conqueror is coming in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania and
there is a possibility that the
fantastic four could debut in that movie
as well but let's not forget about dr
doom because some rumors state that he
might be coming to the mcu sooner than
we think and given some upcoming
projects that are coming to the mcu i
actually think doctor doom is going to
play a much more prominent role overall
than we were actually expecting but
don't worry i'm going to cover
everything you need to know in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the mcu alright
let's start off with marvel's search for
their new director for the fantastic
four movie which is actually pretty good
news i love john watts i think it did
amazing with the homecoming trilogy and
i think spider-man no way home was
fantastic but it looks like marvel
studios is searching for some pretty big
guns here just like they got sam raimi
for multiverse of madness and remember
the power of marvel they did the
eternals which had an insane cast i
don't think any director is off the
table for them and according to justin
krull who is a senior reporter at
deadline marvel has a very long list of
candidates he posted to twitter last
night saying some late night fantastic
for directing search updates while it's
easily marvel's top oda one source says
don't expect it to be filled anytime
soon as they are not even close to
cutting down the long list of candidates
i'd be shocked if a choice is made
before labor day now labor day is
september 5th so that's pretty far out
there but let's continue talking about
what he said on twitter he says two
while no names have surfaced multiple
sources say while it's a large mix of
candidates feige and company are taking
a lot of shots at some big names one
source close to process says kevin
doesn't want to oversee the entire shoot
and after not having to worry about that
with sam raimi he is very game to the
same outcome with this shoot which is
kind of cool because that basically
means that kevin feige doesn't want to
oversee every single little minuscule
thing about the project but he is
putting faith in the directors that he
is hiring now this can be good but this
also can be bad depending on how you
look at it kevin feige is the founder of
the mcu he's the brains behind it
without him there wouldn't be an mcu and
kevin feige is largely responsible for
the success that it's had and part of
that is him overseeing the projects now
that's not going to change kevin feige
will always have final say with whatever
he wants from a movie when he sees it or
hears about it or reads the script so
that's why i'm not too worried about
this because kevin feige will ultimately
have final say but him letting the
directors have some freedom could be a
very good thing after all that's how we
got guardians of the galaxy they brought
in james gunn to direct guardians and
let him do his thing and we got an
amazing franchise from it warner bros
also did that with james gunn for
peacemaker and it was amazing as well so
great things can come out of studios
letting directors do their thing and
according to this report that's what
kevin feige is looking to do hire a very
big name director and let him or her do
their thing which would be fantastic
news pun intended now sadly we've all
been waiting for some casting
information and spoiler alert for doctor
strange and the multiverse madness we
did get john krasinski as mr fantastic
and i'm really hoping he's going to play
the main mcu mr fantastic but since we
probably aren't going to get director
info until labor day that means we
probably aren't going to be getting any
casting info now it doesn't mean that
rumors can't come out or some major
trade companies can't report on casting
but an official announcement from marvel
studios is probably far away however
like i said we do have a little bit of
news about doom in the mcu now many
people might know the insider account on
twitter my time to shine hello she has
been very very accurate with a lot of
things that she's put out there very
accurate so she's considered to be a
reliable source and yesterday somebody
tweeted at her asking how soon till doom
in which she replied closer than you
think now some people are saying that
phase 4 has kind of been off to a slow
start and that things aren't really
connecting that much yet but i think a
lot of that is about to change i think a
lot is about to go down in ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania this is where
king the conqueror is coming in and i
believe the fantastic force still could
be appearing in that movie there were a
lot of rumors going around about that
for a while people were reporting that
it was going to happen but then they
kind of changed their mind and said they
might have heard differently we'll have
to wait and see on that although it does
make sense considering that ant-man 3 is
going to focus on the quantum realm and
kang who originally is nathaniel
richards is a descendant of reed
richards or depending on the comic
storyline you follow could also be a
descendant of doctor doom himself now
doom coming sooner than we think
actually doesn't strike me as that odd
because he might even be connected to
wakanda forever at the end of the first
black panther film t'challa said that
they're going to make their resources
available to the world with of course
their biggest resource being vibranium
and if we know good old victor von doom
he's gonna want some of that vibranium
and we do know that neymar is going to
be in wakanda forever and that he'll be
going up against wakanda however this
kind of might be like a batman vs
superman situation where they fight each
other but then ultimately there's a
bigger villain that they have to band
together to fight now wakanda and
atlantis and the comics don't like each
other that's known so it could just play
out as an all-out war however namor
still is a hero in the comics and will
most likely be a hero in the mcu after
all he is a part of the illuminati in
the comics if there was going to be a
greater villain of this movie i would
really hope that they would tease doctor
doom and that could actually be the
start of setting up the fantastic four
plus not to mention dr doom has some
major connections to wanda and wundigor
mountain which we just saw in multiverse
of madness doom is also very connected
to doctor strange as well in fact one of
the story lines that i would absolutely
love to see in the mcu is doom and
doctor strange going to the hell
dimension to try and defeat mephisto to
get doctor doom's mother back so many
connections here plus that insider
account my time to shine hello she did
say that a scarlet witch solo project is
indeed in the works which has been
rumored for a while now now one last
thing about the fantastic four there is
another account great phase that has
been supposedly leaking a bunch of stuff
recently and this account says that
feige is definitely game to make
fantastic for in a very star trek
inspired way this is among the most
important franchises he's ever done now
i don't really know if we can trust this
account or not so take it with a grain
of salt but one thing that i most surely
know is that this project is indeed very
important to kevin feige it's marvel's
first family so kevin feige is going to
do everything he can to make this an
extremely great movie and if it turns
out somewhat like star trek given us
some of those star trek vibes from 2009
i'm definitely okay with that after all
reed richards is the smartest man alive
and we got a glimpse of his technology
in multiverse of madness how we
teleported into the room i think that
vibe would fit quite well but let me
know what you think about all of this in
the comments down below and let me know
when you would like to see doctor doom
debut what project do you think would
fit his debut the best let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest things in the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof